I'm not a morning person.  But I want to be.
You know, there was a period in my life
when I was waking up at 5:00am everyday
and I loved it!
I would wake up, meditate, write, read, exercise, do my chores,
make breakfast, all before noon!
It was awesome.  I was a productivity machine.
Unfortunately, it only lasted about 6 months.
Until life got a little crazy and I reverted back to my old habits.
I would sleep in late, and of course I would hit the Snooze button.
And hit the Snooze button.
Snooze button.  Snooze.  Snooze.  Snooze.
I desperately want to get back to waking up early.
So I have been devouring articles for any kind of advice
on how to get out of bed.
And I feel like I've tried everything.
You know, I take melatonin and I lay in bed eary.
I put my phone in high places where I can't reach it.
I've even tried using one of those alarm clocks
where you have to shoot it with a toy gun to turn it off.
But every day it's the same story:
I wake up.  I hit Snooze.
And then I go back to bed to cuddle with a cat.
That is until I found this blog by a guy named Steve.
This is what you do:
When you're getting ready to go to bed, set your morning alarm.
But also set a bunch of little alarms
that will occur over the next 15 to 20 minutes
all about 2-3 minutes apart.
But try to do it in a way so that you don't remember exactly
how many alarms you're setting.
Then put your phone out of reach, and go to bed.
Now, when your alarms start to go off,
act like it's the morning.  Do whatever you do in the morning.
For me, that's getting up, turning off my alarms
stretching, and heading to the bathroom to brush my teeth.
But, you'll go back to bed.
You'll try to fall asleep.  And when the next alarm
goes off, you do the same thing.
Repeat, repeat, repeat.
Eventually, this gets so annoying that every time you lay
back down in bed, your body gets sleepier.
And I personally love that because
I have a hard time getting to sleep.
It takes me like 30 minutes to 2 hours
of just laying there to even feel sleepy.
Somehow this practice kind of like tricks
my body into being so annoyed with the mini alarms
that eventually I will just end up falling asleep
once they're all done until the real alarm kicks in, in the morning.
And before you can even think about it, your body
will get up and do whatever it is that you practiced the night before.
So, if you want to be an early riser,
this technique will be mildly annoying but insanely effective.
You're welcome.
I'm Anna Akana.  Stay awesome Gotham.
Oh, and a few announcements.
I have these live shows coming up, I do stand up
improv, and then a little meet and greet afterwards
as a thank you for coming and then we can take fun photos
and I'm usually really sweaty, so just be warned
if you're hugging me and I'm sweaty, I'm sorry.
I also have these short films
"Loose Ends" and "Super & Associates."
I'm super proud and I'm super excited and I hope you like them!
Also, the podcast, Explain Things To Me,
the one where Brad and I interview professionals in various fields
is going to be on iTunes only now
so you can go to itunes.com/ExplainThingsToMe
and listen to all the cool people that we are interviewing there.
Finally, people have asked me for Q&A videos
and unfortunately I don't really want to do a Q&A video for my channel
but I will be doing weekly broadcasts on YouNow so here are the dates and times.
If you can make any of those, and you have a question
I'm happy to answer anything about short filmmaking
or my cats or where I get my cat furniture
or whatever questions you may have.
That's all for the announcements.
Get the fuck out of my house.